je m'appelle il d'alice coup
je suis journaliste c'est pour les gens
qui ne croient pas en toi monte aussi et
journalistes savaient pas qui est élevé
ouais je viens d'arriver est ce que vous
vous connaissez tout était tranquille
par ici victor est prévenu
parce que tu as été aujourd'hui sur les
lieux du crime les milieux du crise
en quittant la ville et la juriste qui
remettrait jamais et puis à vous
pourquoi
en 88
le fils du maire a disparu mais on n'a
jamais su ce qui est arrivé à rick
grasset a pas mon meilleur ami il a été
enlevé
juste devant moi je voulais voir une
copie du rapport de police richie file
du lkp le choc plus de ça il n'est pas
question que je me mêle
je peux pas tout montrer mais voilà déjà
ce que j'ai vous m'aidez pourquoi je
déteste aussi les machos paternaliste
jeune fille tu ne sais pas du tout dans
quoi tu mérites du map est toujours
jeune fille comme si c'était un
compliment mais je sais que ce n'est pas
vraiment pas ce que tu as fait je suis
journaliste non à une écolière j'ai
toute une vie pleine de personnes qui en
savent plus que moi sur l'homme que j'ai
épousé
et quelque chose que tu devrais savoir l
sécher l'école pour aller interroger le
suspect du meurtre
non enfin oui mais non dans notre
famille on règle nos problèmes
[Musique]
entre toi ma ligne je préfèrerais me
montrer courageuse tu devras être les
deux
[Musique]